WILL BE MAKING COMMENTS IN THE
NEXT HOUR.
>>> ALSO NEW THIS MORNING,
RAPPER TRAVIS SCOTT SPEAKING OUT
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE THAT
CHAOTIC CONCERT IN HOUSTON.
THE ASTROWORLD FESTIVAL.
ULTIMATELY TEN PEOPLE DIED, THAT
CROWD SURGED TOWARD THE STAGE.
WELL, SCOTT APPEARED ON THE
MORNING RADIO SHOW "THE
BREAKFAST CLUB" DISCUSSING THE
TRAGEDY THAT HAS NOW LED TO
MULTIPLE LAWSUITS AGAINST HIM,
OTHER PERFORMERS AND THE
CONCERT'S ORGANIZERS.
SCOTT ADDRESSED CRITICISM HE
CONTINUED HIS PERFORMANCE,
DESPITE THE PRESENCE OF
EMERGENCY VEHICLES IN THE CROWD.
>> CNN'S ROSA FLORES HAS BEEN
COVERING.
ONE OF THE KEY QUESTIONS HERE
HAS BEEN WAS HE AWARE AT ALL,
WAS IT COMMUNICATED TO HIM WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN THE CROWD AS
PEOPLE WERE BEGINNING TO BE
INJURED?
WHAT DID HE SAY?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, ABOUT
THAT POINT, JIM, TRAVIS SCOTT
SAYS THAT HE DIDN'T KNOW THE
SEVERITY OF THE SITUATION AT THE
CONCERT.
THAT'S WHAT HE HAD SAID IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS TRAGEDY.
NOW, THIS IS AN INTERVIEW THAT
LASTED ABOUT AN HOUR LONG.
I'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO GO THROUGH
THE ENTIRE THING.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT HE
SPEAKS ABOUT THE MOMENT HE
LEARNED THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY
DIED AT HIS CONCERT.
AND HE SAYS THIS WAS MOMENTS
BEFORE THE PRESS CONFERENCE
WHERE THIS WAS ANNOUNCED.
NOW, CHARLAMAGNE THA GOD ASKS
HIM ABOUT THIS RAGE AT THE
CONCERT, AT HIS CONCERT, HE'S
KNOWN FOR, AND TRAVIS SCOTT SAYS
THAT'S ABOUT LETTING GO, THAT'S
ABOUT HAVING FUN.
BUT HE DOES MENTION SOMETHING
THAT I HEARD FROM CONCERTGOERS
HERE ON THE GROUND, AND THAT WAS
ABOUT THE MOMENTS DURING THE
CONCERT, WHERE TRAVIS SCOTT
PAUSED THE CONCERT TO DIRECT AID
TO CERTAIN PORTIONS OF THE
VENUE.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> YOU KNOW, PEOPLE PASS OUT,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE, YOU KNOW,
THINGS HAPPEN AT CONCERTS.
BUT SOMETHING LIKE THAT, JUST,
LIKE --
>> PEOPLE SAID THEY COLLECTIVELY
HEARD FOLKS SCREAMING HELP EVERY
TIME YOU STOPPED THE SONG TO GET
YOUR ATTENTION.
DID YOU HEAR ANY OF THOSE
SCREAMS?
>> NO, MAN.
YOU KNOW, IT IS SO CRAZY,
BECAUSE I'M AN ARTIST TOO.
ANYTIME YOU CAN HEAR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT YOU WANT TO STOP THE
SHOW.
I STOPPED IT A COUPLE OF TIMES
TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY WAS OKAY.
AND I JUST REALLY JUST GO OFF
THE FANS' ENERGY AS A
COLLECTIVE, YOU KNOW.
CALL IT RESPONSE.
AND I JUST DIDN'T HEAR THAT.
>> Reporter: NOW, TRAVIS SCOTT
GOES ON TO SAY THAT IF SOMETHING
DETRIMENTAL WOULD HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING, SOMETHING URGENT, HE
THOUGHT HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
NOTIFIED ON STAGE TO STOP THE
SHOW.
AND GOES ON TO SAY THAT DID NOT
HAPPEN.
NOW, MORE THAN 140 LAWSUITS HAVE
BEEN FILED IN THIS TRAGEDY.
THE DEFENDANTS INCLUDE TRAVIS
SCOTT, LIVENATION, THE
ORGANIZERS, AND THE ALLEGATIONS
IS THERE WAS NEGLIGENCE, GROSS
NEGLIGENCE, THE ORGANIZERS, THE
STAR RAPPER, THEY WERE MADE OUT
TO MAKE A TON OF MONEY FROM THE
CONCERT AND THAT TEN PEOPLE HAVE
DIED DURING THE LATEST COURT
FILINGS.
TRAVIS SCOTT HAS -- THROUGH HIS
ATTORNEYS, HAS DENIED LEGAL
LIABILITY AND, JIM AND ERICA,
WE'RE STILL REACHING OUT TO A
LOT OF THESE PLAINTIFFS TO GET
REACTION FROM THEM, BUT, OF
COURSE, THEY'RE DISPLEASED WITH
THIS DENIAL OF LEGAL LIABILITY
FROM TRAVIS SCOTT AND JUST FROM
THE STATEMENT THAT WE DID GET
FROM THE YOUNGEST VICTIM, THE
9-YEAR-OLD'S FAMILY, THAT
ATTORNEY WAS VERY DISPLEASED,
SAYING THE FAMILY DID NOT ACCEPT
TRAVIS SCOTT'S OFFER TO PAY FOR
THE FUNE